hello folks
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel today
is a interesting episode we are here
with the two legends that are mit phd
dr keith shitpost to duggar and also
alex bazian stenlake we spent an hour or
so talking about the theory of
computation
intelligence bayesian model selection
the intelligence explosion
and also for 30 minutes or so we covered
this really interesting distill
dot pub article on interactive articles
distill.pub is an open source publishing
platform
which promulgates information in a
really innovative way rather than just
the traditional scientific papers of old
where it's just lots of mathematical
formulas
and language now the focus is on
animations and graphics and
interactivity and simulations
allowing us to communicate ideas more
powerfully and more effectively
but there are some trade-offs to the to
this approach because it means that
it can't be consumed via standardized
channels as it's harder to
create that kind of content so we'll go
into detail on that
anyway i hope you enjoy the episode
today remember
to like comment and subscribe and we'll
see you back
next week tony horror has this brilliant
quote
there are two ways to do software design
you either make it so simple
there are obviously no errors or you
make it so complicated there are no
obvious errors
[Laughter]
we've got alex on tomorrow to talk about
kernel methods
cool and so i need to study chapter 6 of
prml today oh do you yeah yeah
they're a very practical practically
useful tool
yeah that's they're they're rarely gonna
get you state of the art but they have
their
utility on any limited compute platforms
they have a special place in my heart
even if they're a bit old hat
hey what's old is new so maybe not
if not this year five years from now
they could be renamed
to something else and become state of
the art um
to give away some of the spoilers here
attention mechanisms are just kernel
maps
the way to start pulling them apart is
old-school kernel theory
view it as an attention kernel and
what's going on there makes a lot more
sense
plus you know like all the sparse kernel
stuff
like it's starting to come through with
randomized kernels and stuff but i
really want to see some of that uh old
school sparse kernel literature come
into the
attention systems that are coming
through these days yeah it makes you
think that everything is everything
because someone commented on our youtube
video yesterday saying that
oh don't you know that transformers are
rnns
and therefore that because keith and i
were basically saying that these
statistical language models are
they just learned these kind of
crappy patterns and so on and we were
using
uh a feature visualization of a cnn as
an example of this we're saying language
models are just doing the same thing
but they are basically rnns apparently
which at which means they are too
incomplete
and they could actually represent a
context-free grammar
so they could be learning the rules of
language basically maybe it's not
it made me think because they are
computer programs
but they're not like computer programs
because they're neural networks they
just do all of these matrix
multiplications so
could they really represent a
context-free grammar what's the
intuition there even if we get a very
good facsimile of a language or a
language model
like how close of a facsimile is it and
how much of the things that we feel
define a language do we are reflected in
there how much
things like nuance things like implicit
meaning
that um yeah well i haven't i have an
answer to
that one so cfgs contacts three grammars
they are
computable by turing machines right by
even simpler machines i think uh push
down automata for example
can recognize cfgs natural languages
are csgs they're context-sensitive
grammars
okay right and i think a lot of times
people throw out this xyz
is turning complete or whatever but they
lied
the fact that an actual turing machine
has an infinite
amount of memory right so no actual
practical machine is actually a turing
machine
because none of them have infinite
amounts of memory and then they also
allied
how things scale okay fine if if rnns
are quote unquote turing complete as say
like a
computational machine how does the
amount of memory
or circuitry or whatever that they
require
to calculate a particular thing how does
that scale with the size of the input
if we want them to recognize all context
sensitives
sentences of 1 000 characters versus 10
000 characters do they grow
quadratically
exponentially yeah that's all just left
out right oh it's turned complete
therefore
yeah all our problems are going away
it's like now
we care a lot about efficiency like
concept of efficiency
is coming up tim with sort of chalet's
concept of intelligence and
and whatnot yeah i guess everything
could be computed with
an infinitely large number of nand
gates is are those intelligent well
we don't know there's there's some
cool stuff coming out of the i guess
it's the control theory literature
looking at
they're called competement operators and
basically what they let you do is take
this non-linear pro
non-linear problem and reduce it to a
linear problem
and all you need is infinite dimensions
right sure easy
and practice that means you truncate
your svd at a couple of hundred but
you know all the proofs go out the
window everyone says oh we can do this
because it's theoretically justified
of course it's probably not so
theoretically justified
infinity yeah it's a good concept
right damn something so
should we jump in actually should we
jump into it because
i'm sure we're going to go down some
rabbit holes anyway
i'm so tempted just to continue this
conversation we were having because
you know we were talking about before
keith and i were saying
do neural networks reason or not and
keith made the argument that you can
unroll them
so it doesn't matter that it's a neural
network you can unroll it doesn't you
know
needing looping semantics and conditions
yeah you can unroll it into something
yeah
networks so it is reasoning but then
other things come into the mix so you
mentioned
efficiency because if you have a
function that sorts
a bunch of numbers right what you could
do is you could just memorize
n factorial permutations so you just
have a memorization machine
clearly it's clearly not doing any
reasoning it's just
retrieving that sorted list and and then
then you have the concept of
generalization which is charlay's things
if you're memorizing everything
you're not generalizing by definition so
there seems to be some kind of trade-off
between
generalization memorization and
efficiency
so that's why i'm going to come back to
the scaling thing so the first class i
ever took that made me realize
yeah i have natural limitations was the
theory of computation
so i took the theory of computation from
michael sipser actually he's written
as a well-known theory of computation
guy and uh professor
and it was very mind-bending in some
parts and strained the limits of
my personal neural net capabilities the
core
aspect of analyzing computation is
looking at
scalability so for example the
difference between
you know the difference between an np
complete problem
versus a polynomial problem is one of
scaling because if you just take a
finite input
that's any problem is it's finite like
we can a traveling salesman problem
with whatever 50 nodes or something
eventually you can solve that problem
with just waiting long enough computing
long enough the point is that as you
increase that number as how it scales
within
number of nodes scales in a much
different way than a polynomial problem
so
if we don't pay attention to the scaling
i don't think we're really going to get
anywhere and so
with the unrolling thing that i brought
up in the last call
okay a multiplication circuit if we
unroll that so that it can be
computed in a single cycle on a single
flow of electrons through enough
nand gates and i don't know because i'm
not a circuit designer but let's suppose
to do
8-bit multiplication we need a certain
number of circuits
and now to do 16 bits if that actually
goes up by say
to the two or two to the scale if it's
exponential growth
versus how much circuitry do i need to
do it iteratively
maybe it's far less than that then yes
in principle you can do it with a
splayed out static circuit but it scales
very differently
and so if your concept of quote
intelligence
really is more formally defined to
include some of these scaling aspects
then i think we maybe get at the heart
of what we're
we're talking about when we're talking
about reasoning and that sort of thing
how would you link the scaling because
we're talking about two different
substrates of computation i think you're
talking about traditional
code and then we're talking about neural
networks so with traditional code
something like the traveling salesman
problem it's got a
i think it's got an exponential time
complexity i think it's two to the n or
something i can't remember but
it's huge but once you've found the
optimal solution
then you've got it right so
it's super quick but neural networks are
a bit different because you have a
training phase
and then now with these gpt models you
need a hell of a lot of computation just
to
after you've trained it just to do the
inferencing so
how would you compare the two paradigms
i
i would look at their time space
trade-off the sort of
traditional and in this case space would
be the the size of the circuit
so and if we set let's suppose we set
the requirements of
i want a program that that solves
the problem of the traveling salesman
exactly so
no probabilistic solutions no monte
carlo no las vegas algorithms but just
actually
solves it okay and if i don't have time
so if i just have a static circuit that
needs to evaluate it
then if i can handle problems of up to n
nodes
then i need some function of n number of
uh
nodes and i'm using nodes here n number
of
states to visit or locations then i need
n number of nodes
in my neural network whereas if i can do
iteration
i need some other number of of um
nodes in that circuitry and it's going
to be a much smaller number
so i think that's where you would look
to start to compare
how intelligent things are in terms of
this efficiency metric of
what problems can they solve per you
know pound for pounds sort of per
circuit
per this is time space trade-off because
the neural network
if it can solve the problem exactly
we'll give it to you in this sort of
single pass which
let's just say that takes unit time
whereas the thing that's computing
maybe will take 32 units or whatever the
number is
but i think one of the reasons why the
two paradigms are different though
is tsp or sorting
it's structured so you can analytically
enumerate
all of the possible routes and as we
said
it's two to the end it's ridiculously
high whereas
with a computer vision algorithm and a
neural network it has to be statistical
you have to have some kind of
representation
cnn has this trick with the receptive
field
the weight sharing and so on these
filters it you couldn't possibly
enumerate
all of the pixel space because that
would just be insane
that's okay so then you're just
redefining the what what the definition
of success is like is it i got within x
percent of the correct answer y percent
of the time that sort of thing
and i i think it's worth noting that you
can enumerate like
for a sufficiently small pixel space you
can enumerate
all possible combinations um and
like we're doing discrete maths here
fundamentally it's going to be discrete
at some level
if your neural network's small enough
you may even be able to fit it on like a
multi-terabyte hard drive
but you know all we're doing is we're
finding in a proc an efficient
approximation scheme
the reason that it gets hard with things
like traveling salesmen
is because the underlying space isn't
necessarily regular
and like some standard dimensionality
you know the relationships can change so
we can't just fit the whole thing neatly
into
a fixed matrix size a fixed matrix space
and solve it there
even now mate if we use a matrix
representation of the graphs
we're dealing with graphs of different
sizes that and
if we know anything about graphs it's
that local and global topology kind of
interact in these very strange ways
that may not necessarily generalize
between different size graphs
you said if we made the problem small
enough but even if you had a three by
three
grid and you had three color channels
and you had
a 32-bit i don't know what what what's
the data structure for the pixels
it'd be it'd be eight bit um unsigned
floats because that's typically how it's
stored
okay so that's two to the power of eight
times three cubed it's pretty big
already yeah
sure these things do grow quickly these
time space
trade-offs there can be very high
scalings in either dimensions quite
common in space dimension
and the only reason why i brought this
up is just i think we need to just be
careful again because
i don't want to be in a situation where
some particular black box
okay we deem that it's reasoning like
okay
everybody agrees this black box is uh
reasoning and when we put in inputs we
get the answer back
in five minutes or something and then
it's doing some reasoning there
and then when version nine of that black
so alpha nine
comes out going back to the alpha zero
thing when alpha nine comes out
all of a sudden when we put in the
problem we actually get the answer back
in one nanosecond
because it just the circuit inside there
got so
complex that just some electrons pass
through there and
boom like the answer comes out now oh
now this thing is stupid man like it's
not even thinking about anything it's
just giving the answer like
instantaneously that's not a reasoning
machine
there's i don't know if you guys ever
read the original graph i don't know if
it was the original graph neural network
papers but it'd be one of the first big
ones that google kind of did as par
part of the gnn push but they motivated
that paper with an interesting analogy
taken from known
noam chomsky talking about intelligence
and reasoning as the ability to combine
you know or to take two existing ideas
and synthesize them
into a third potentially unrelated idea
a novel idea
and i don't wonder if that's kind of
what we're missing here the ability to
like is it reasoning if we do a pass and
we get an answer
we're getting an answer but that doesn't
feel like reasoning if if we're going to
talk about reasoning in this sense i
think it almost has to have an
element of synthesis of creation of new
ideas
so things like alpha zero when it's once
it's trained it's not really
reasoning anymore it's just a very
efficient search
a very efficient a tree search and i
think in the background of those
algorithms that there actually is a tree
search that's just optimized using
the actual search space itself for the
board state is um
is simplified using a cnn or some
something like that
i don't remember the details but to get
to this idea of reasoning it may not
necessarily have to be iterative
but i think it almost has to be
combinatorial
it's quite an interesting assertion so
chomsky thought that
intelligence was about synthesizing
ideas
and don't i agree because
if you look at evolution or an
evolutionary algorithm but i think
really because it
evolutionary algorithms are actually
quite convergent but if you look at real
evolution
that's doing what you said it's using
concepts together
in a new way to form to synthesize
something new
and that's super interesting because
because
you were saying that that reasoning is
uh deductive
and that seems like a contradiction from
something that could synthesize
something
yeah i wouldn't necessarily say it's
strictly deductive
i'd say there is probably an inductive
element there to say hey this thing may
apply to a new situation where i haven't
necessarily seen it before
but again i'm getting into territory
where i'm starting to feel a little
foolish because i'm anthropomorphizing
an
algorithm at this point i this is the
point where i normally get very cautious
and start warning
business people to hey don't think this
is a thinking object it's a
it's a bunch of maths but if we are
going to think of it as a bunch of maths
thinking of it as function composition
but function composition
with respect to some input maybe that's
a useful paradigm for thinking about
this
and i still haven't read chalet's work
everyone so i know i'm letting the team
down here
oh yeah that's all right i was just
thinking maybe we should start up a
little
drinking game where every time chomsky's
name is mentioned we have to take like a
sip of something
i'm happy to leave him up it just came
up in the paper i i didn't bring this
up that was their motivation don't blame
me don't blame them
so i hear what what you're both saying i
think uh i kind of i don't want to beat
a dead horse here
am i allowed to say that is that
offensive in any i don't know but i
don't want to keep repeating myself
let's say
it's just that what worries me is that
as we start to formalize what is
reasoning
and whatever it comes out to be let's
just say one day
we decide lambda calculus is is
reasoning
or second order logic is reasoning and
it's like a throwback to the
expert system days and if we start with
some statements and can deduce
new statements then that's reasoning my
worry is that
as we formalize that we may eventually
decide that nothing is intelligent
anymore
that because maybe after we learn more
about
expert systems or lambda calculus or
whatnot people will lose their
fascination with it and say
yeah you know what that's not actually
reasoning anymore and and eventually
we're just going to find out that humans
aren't actually intelligent either
and we're not actually reasoning well
monty python had that song about that
you better hope there's intelligent life
somewhere out there because there's
bugger all of it down here on earth
that's that's hilarious on that point as
well because you can start with humans
we know humans are intelligent
and sam harris has some interesting
thought experiments on this about you
can subdivide
consciousness many ways and you can
separate the hemispheres of the brain
and they're independently conscious
and when you move over to neural
networks well clearly they're not
consciousness and
there's a problem in philosophy i think
where at what point do you become bald
or at what point does um
a pile of sand become a pile of sand
because if you just keep putting grains
and grains into a pile
at some point it'll become a pile of
sand and similarly at some point
there'll be intelligence and there'll be
consciousness which is a bit of an
offshoot
consciousness seems to be something
which is completely separate from
intelligence
but surely this is just an argument for
a fuzzy set because there's
there's degrees of being a pile of sand
doesn't have to be one moment a pile of
sand in the next second
not a pile of sand oh we're working in
reverse here obviously
i i don't know like i think that's
spurious argument at what point does
consciousness emerge
what point does intelligence emerge
maybe it's just a thing that
the more you have like the more neurons
you stack together the more
you get something that looks like an
intelligent system that
if we think of it purely in terms of the
neurons then we're going to back
ourselves into this corner where it's
just a matter of throwing enough compute
at a thing
yes so look tim maybe let's agree
that humans are intelligent i'm happy
with that and then
if we just say that he's part of our
definition
that whatever's going on up in our brain
we're going to say that's intelligent
what i want to make sure is that it's
consistent in the sense that if we start
to find
machines that do subsets so that we
don't decide those are not intelligent
because even though they're doing the
same thing that that we do at least in
part and i completely agree with alex
which is
hey let's just put a number on it let's
call it a iq
for example and we'll just say that
alpha zero
and the chess domain has an iq of this
whereas gary kasparov
has an iq of maybe more because not
because
he can beat alpha zero at standard chess
but
but if you had him play fischer random
or something like that he could take
those ideas and translate it over much
more effectively than alpha zero could
and so we can cut this measure of
intelligence or a iq
artificial intelligence quotient
whatever you want
and but we just don't want to be in a
situation where we have to constantly
keep changing our definitions
because we find machines that under that
definition
are intelligent and we don't like the
fact that machines are intelligent
type of thing yeah and that was
one of the principal reasons why charlay
conceived it as the information
conversion ratio
so how efficiently can you turn
information into something which
generalizes to
lots of situations right because if you
don't have something like that
charlay's big thing is that being good
at a skill it means nothing
because you can buy skill and you can
just create a massive neural network and
you can put loads of prizes and
experience into it
and it's going to do something really
well but that's rubbish because as you
say
you play a different variant of chess
and now it's it's completely useless
whereas
gary kasparov would be able to reuse
many of his concepts from chess and also
the fact that he learned to play chess
so efficiently in the first place
implies that he would be able to learn
a new game and you say efficiency there
again and i think
i'm i'm starting to just come to this
that efficiency is a
key aspect of intelligence because fine
i could build this circuit with
x mini parameters and spend x amount of
time
training it and then it can give answers
in y amount of time
but in that with that same physical or
that same
logical set of resources could i have
done more
i think so i think we can definitely do
far better than just current
neural networks by whatever we've talked
about lots of possible enhancements of
it so i think if we include this
efficiency idea
as part of our measure of that aiq if
you will
it's probably an important factor to
consider
and this is why the meta learning
literature is so fascinating especially
zero and one-shot learning cases
where they're literally trying to learn
how to generalize
it's still pretty rudimentary at this
point in time
but the work that's coming out of there
already shows you know promise for
industrial applications massively
reducing data volumes etc
but in the reinforcement learning case
learning from
from single episodes that's
that sort of area there is starting to
feel like where intelligence is coming
from and you're starting to see these
interesting conceptualizations of
how to build something that learns fast
i think that's
worth you know keeping an eye on for
exactly this reason
the focus is no longer how do we do a
task really well
it's how do we do a task well enough
with zero experience
or bare minimal experience and
statistical
procedures uh we used to call this kind
of stuff statistic
so i feel fair in saying that they've
always been terrible at this it's just
horrifically bad so like most people i
went through an orthodox
statistics education and always thought
it was quite cook bookish and arbitrary
and never really found it that
interesting
and i was trying to analyze problems in
graduate school where i was collecting
uh photons i was i was doing two photon
fluorescence microscopy and i was
collecting photons at very high sort of
scanning speeds and so for a particular
voxel
i may have a small number of photons
let's say 25
30 that got collected and i was trying
to calculate the lifetime
of the fluorophores in there and i could
plot these things on a graph
and and see with my eye what the decay
rate was but i needed a statistical
procedure to calculate this so i'm out
there reading papers and looking for
proper ways to do this and find a paper
that lo and behold
is how many photons do i need to measure
the lifetime of a fluorophore
and it goes through all kinds of
statistics shannon entropy
blah blah or information whatever and
concludes it
yeah you need 10 000 photons i'm like
crap i've only got 25 photons but i can
see it with my eye
why do i need 10 000 photons and
about that same time and this is one of
these freak coincidences in life
i'm sitting in the office and my
colleague is over there laughing
he's reading a book and just laughing so
i walk over hey mike what do you what
book you read there it is oh
i'm reading this book called uh data
analysis of bayesian tutorial
and it's showing how sort of traditional
statistics just totally breaks down
where if you use this other method it
works just perfectly fine
can i see that book for a minute i take
it i read it this begins my whole
exploration into probability theory is a
generalization of logic
right and and bayesian analysis and
whatever and i realize that we
we teach this really silly path where we
extract
so little information from the data with
so many arbitrary rules and calculations
that it just doesn't work well i
remember having these arguments with
people
because bayesian data analysis three is
one of my bibles
and i i remember chatting with all these
people that were like
biologists that are looking for p-values
and everything they're like oh the
p-values tell us what we're looking for
so let me tell you you don't need that
much data you just need to make some
assumptions over the space and they're
like yeah but we're going to bias our
estimates
your value is not going to lie up near
infinity or negative infinity we can say
that much it'll be somewhere between
like plus or minus 10 standard
deviations if we assume normality
we're making the same assumptions we're
just making the search so much more
efficient
and here are all the other things that
you'll get yeah this whole thing we're
going to bias our estimates what's
what was hilarious to me is after i
started learning about bayesian analysis
i started making all kinds of
connections to the statistics i had been
taught
and i finally had a mathematical
foundation to understand things
oh to unbias our variance estimate
instead of dividing by
n we need to divide by n minus 1 or n
plus 1 or whatever why where's that come
from what mathematical basis do you have
for that
actually that corresponds to different
assumptions about the prior
for the the variance if you use
jeffrey's prior then it's
minus one if you use a constant prior
it's just plus a zero in other words
it's n
plus gamma or gamma is the power that
you use for that thing and so you have a
mathematical foundation for this
and it's not that it's not that orthodox
statistics
is not making prior assumptions it's
just hiding them
and it's doing so arbitrarily and
ignoring them yeah
they're alex yeah i was just like
amending
this idea it's really hard to to make
this argument to people because they
think they're doing the right thing
but i remember teaching some psychology
students they were
talking about oh yeah but how do we know
if we're making these assumptions then
how we know that we're actually finding
things and until i unpacked look you're
making exactly the same assumptions in
fact you're making
dumber assumptions over here yeah yeah
make some smart assumptions
make your job easy it's hard to like
psychology is super noisy you're going
to be dealing with
you know enough problems don't make your
job any harder than it has to be
this is quite interesting though because
keith and i have been talking ad nauseum
about how we introduce priors into the
machine learning process because
statistics has loads of priors about the
stochastic
data producing mechanism but the beauty
of it is
if you do make those assumptions then
you have so much more parsimony
stay tuned for when we talk about kernel
methods and choice of kernel functions
but part of the part of the big problem
is that
to do probabilistic optimization it's
like all integrals
and so if you're not doing monte carlo
methods
you know which are going to be hideously
inefficient you need to find
some cheap and effective way to
to even estimate those probabilistic
models in the first place
and then on top of that what does it
mean to be a prior
neural network and you can say okay our
weights are gaussian cool we're doing
something gaussian processing
okay we want to say that we expect it to
be a wide tail distribution
how can we even formalize that in the i
guess that's probably the
question you guys have been discussing
but
i don't necessarily see a way forward
there because we don't really have a
theoretical
a theoretically grounded model of how a
neural network
behaves at a more fundamental level than
oh the gradients are going to do this
okay the gradients are doing that why
are they doing that
until we get that yeah yeah and on that
one one of the issues is
that neural networks is a weird
substrate to create priors
because again we were talking yesterday
about having
there's a dichotomy between prize and
experience and you could create a 3d
graphics simulator
which would allow you to do spatial
reasoning so the ball can't intersect
the wall
and then you could generate infinite
amounts of experience and put it into
the neural network
but the elephant in the room here the
real problem is that you can't create
useful inductive prys in the substrate
of the neural network all of the
inductive priors are crap
they're things like the cnn they're
they're things that are
working in this weird substrate of a
planar manifold and making weird
assumptions that bear
absolutely no resemblance whatsoever to
our physical reality
there are some really interesting
attempts to do this sort of stuff
every attempt i've seen has been like
basically unsuccessful
but there are people experimenting
around with for example strange algebras
to try and encode say periodicity and
what was that paper a couple of weeks
ago there was a paper released
about using neural networks to compress
images by mapping directly from the the
pixel coordinate space to the pixel
intensity space and they one of the
tricks there was they were using
cosine you know periodic activation
functions
so i i think it's not impossible to
encode
some information there but doing so in a
principled way
that would correspond to the sorts of
invariancies we want like i've been
doing a lot of slam
up until a few weeks ago and a lot of
image alignment stuff we're doing lee
algebras we're looking at
image homographies there's a manifold
there
that if we could somehow encode it it
would render the problem trivial
but even approaching that problem is
just
the stuff of nightmares you end up
breaking more than you fix
and i i want to pull back to something
alex that you said earlier because
as much as priors are talked about and
tacked and whatever in the
in sort so let's say the bayesian kind
of space
they're actually they're they're not the
biggest part of the problem
the biggest problem we face is what you
brought up which is marginalization
calculating these integrals right it's
you know for example
it's very easy to derive that the math
that you need to perform
to get the answer you want under a set
of a model and a set of priors
doesn't really the priors aren't
actually really that important in a lot
of cases
but to get the parsimonious answer that
you want to do
model selection for example to actually
figure out
should i have five parameters or seven
or six
which is actually more likely given the
data in order to calculate that you have
to do these multi-dimensional
integrals and we just can't we can't we
just don't have a good way of doing that
and so
we know what we're supposed to be doing
it's too hard to do computationally
so instead we we run on to approximate
techniques or whatever or to make
ourselves feel better
some people just say oh no we shouldn't
be doing marginals that's all
nonsense that's subjective blah blah
blah it's actually not those are just
excuses to just to make up for the fact
that we can't do what we know we should
be doing
yeah just on that though a classic
example of
a marginal is we were talking about
interpretability methods
right and there's the partial dependency
plot and that basically marginalizes
over
all of the things that you don't that
you're not interested in so you can just
focus on one of the features
and what that's basically doing is it's
extrapolating across
all of the other features so it's it's
stupid right and and
there might be lots of um complex
interactions between those features
which this method is ignoring
so yeah marginalization isn't
necessarily a good thing
oh no marginalization if it's
mathematically
demanded is exactly what should be done
and it's a good thing to do
what we're doing right now with neural
networks is we're just constantly doing
maximum likelihood
right we're just creating the network
that happens to be the single point
in this complex geometry that gives us
the
the optimal value are you telling me
that that all the other information
surrounding that point is not useful
that's absurd if there's a complex
geometry there and by the way i wasn't
saying you tim telling me that's
people in general telling us right that
this just to ignore everything except
the
perfectly maximal likelihood optimal
solution
and whatever it is whether it's neural
networks any model it doesn't matter
and if you really need what the math
tells you really need to do
is you have to explore that landscape
you have to do some averaging over that
you have to combine that with the
sort of information complexity of the
parameters themselves that you're
optimizing
and all that has to be taken into
account and we're just not doing that
because it's mathematically intractable
on that one one of the first tastes i
had of basing deep learning was from
gals kind of magnum opus where he was
putting together
a bayesian theory of dropout which kind
of does exactly what you're talking
about instead of looking at a single
point
we do multiple dropped out passes
through our network
which in essence kind of samples from it
it bootstraps our model it's it's not a
sample from the distribution but it
could be treated
like a sample from the distribution and
so we sample
from this model multiple times or this
model
and then we can average over the outputs
and we get fairly principled uncertainty
estimates etc
so it's not that it's completely
intractable it's just that these
approximations are often
they're not good they don't accurately
reflect the the true uncertainty in
these parameters because they're not
designed to it it's a hat
and that's an approximation that's the
approximation right the actual
the marginal you would have to really do
would be some mixed integer
multi-dimensional integral i had a
friend doing hamiltonian monte carlo
over entire neural networks and you know
i used to laugh at him
isn't this the fundamental problem in
machine learning in general so as you're
saying
we do this maximal likelihood
estimation and what we really want to
know is
the probability of everything else and
then we want to normalize by that
because even in yan lacoon's energy
based models he uses this
gibbs distribution yeah so
even if within a certain dimensionality
let's say n parameters
even if we we decided that we're going
to use maximum likelihood within that
m parameters like okay you know that's a
little bit of a problem the bigger
problem is
how are we comparing that m parameter
space versus n
plus one parameter space and n minus one
parameter space and there's all kinds of
hacks to do it for example
in other in other contexts let's say aic
whatever it is uh
akaki information criteria or whatever
that's a complete
total hack bic is a complete total hack
if you're lucky enough to find cic paper
written by carlos rodriguez he'll have a
much better
explanation about at least something
that starts to approximate
what you should be doing because he
calculates curvature metric
at the maximum likelihood and it gets
penalized and it's sort of closer to
what the marginals would actually give
you
but again that's at a single point in
that space and it's
a there's a multiple optimum in there
and it's a far more complex thing
do you think that the models would be
significantly better though if we could
computer oh yeah
i i have no doubt that they would
because i know in lower dimensional
spaces
where you can do that and where i have
done that in the past for
real world problems the performance just
obliterates
the hacks it's so superior but on this
mle thing
essentially you would just use it to
compute a better probability
it's the distribution of potential model
parameters with mle you're just finding
the single most likely single parameter
value
but there are multiple because there are
multiple parameter
values that can give rise to your model
especially if there's like hidden
covariance structures or something
if you throw away that information then
you end up with a brittle model that may
not accurately reflect
what it will not at all reflect the
uncertainty over those parameters
particularly
imagine you've got two highly correlated
parameters out of say 10.
stable enough to converge but you can't
be very hard-pressed to tell which one's
actually contributing to your solution
and so the uncertainty over those two
should be that should be
the uncertainty over those two
parameters and now
yeah sorry alex what bayesian you know
what the sort of bayesian model
selection which
which is what requires these
marginalization calculations really buys
you
is parsimony it's the way of controlling
model complexity and that's what buys
you generalization or that's what buys
you
accuracy outside of the training set so
you would find that they would just
perform
far better out of sample if we actually
control their complexity
using proper you know theoretically
sound complexity controls
rather than just arbitrary things lasso
and the linear space
dropout layers and ml these are all just
hacks that are
not even remotely close but it sounds
like a contradiction though because you
were saying earlier that neural networks
um have this explosion of parameters
and yeah they're just they're exploding
in complexity and then
that's what you're describing here for
the bayesian models because you're
saying no this controls that if we could
have this parameter space where we
have every possible result for every
combination of parameters then it would
generalize better
isn't that the same as saying that
neural networks are too big
oh no what i'm saying is that this basin
this methodology marginal
sort of model selection criteria
actually
penalizes you very heavily for
introducing more and more complexity
so it's what would keep rains on this
complexity
in a theoretically sound way and i just
know
in lower dimensional cases where you can
actually compute this it works wonders
i might be clutching at straws here but
the model itself might be parsimonious
but you still need to compute that
integral
and you need to have all of that
information
to have something which will give you
the generalization you're talking about
so forget about the model it's actually
holding in memory
that integral is what gives you what
you're
uh proposing oh it's actually bigger
than the neural network
yeah but it's only the training it's
only the training phase
in which this happens so it's just even
then if you compute the integral it'll
give you a very complex
multi-dimensional landscape
and you need to do something with that
landscape
yeah actually computing the integral
reduces the dimensionality
that's what it does is that you're
integrating over many dimensions to come
down to one number basically which is
the probability of this model so what
you would end up with
is a a probability distribution on the
possible neural networks
and the ones that are more complex would
be heavily penalized and so what would
happen is
you would end up selecting as the model
a much simpler neural network and that
will be
have much better generalization accuracy
you know better parsimony et cetera
so the analogy here just to translate it
into conventional terms
would be instead of doing grid search
over a number of layers or architecture
or whatever you want
that just comes for free as part of the
process you can say
it's most likely that we should be if
you're assuming that we could even
formulate this and we can't and we
definitely can't compute it
but you could say the most likely model
that gives us the optimal solution
is a resnet 18 with the following
parameters because you can actually take
the gradients
then back to the hyper parameters
themselves and and figure out what the
likelihood of your hyper parameters
are sorry but didn't you just say before
that
because maximum likelihood estimation is
that not what you've just described so
that's saying
i'm going to find all of the different
possible parameters
it's going to see what the results are
it's the difference between a normal
distribution and the mean of a normal
distribution
right you you swap out your thinking
instead of thinking of fixed parameter
values you just think
every parameter value in your entire
modeling landscape
is a little distribution and you are
setting the mean and variance there sure
so it's it's maximum likelihood on a far
reduced
space so because you do all these
marginalizations to strip away
every dimension down to a single number
which is the probability of the model
and then sure at that point i'm
selecting the most likely model
and i'm only doing that by the way is a
hack because
really i should be using all the models
simultaneously with their assigned
probability um which is i can't even
imagine
how complicated that problem is but i
think that the real key
takeaway here is just that we know how
to actually properly
constrain complexity mathematically we
just can't calculate it
it's just now it's kind of like gr we
know that we know the
equations but it's really hard to
calculate solutions
even in ideal setups and
far from it to calculate in like an
actual solar system or something
score one for rabbit holes yeah i'm glad
we took a detour into
bay's land because i don't know i think
the whole
the bayesian approach it gets overlooked
and
it's super powerful and who cares if we
can't calculate anything
it's like it allows us to understand our
hacks better
at least it's fine to do the wrong thing
as long as you're doing the wrong thing
sure yeah it's and it's good to keep an
eye out
on what the right thing is because then
as we as a sort of
civilization contemplate that and
cogitate it over time somebody out there
will find
some better tricks that we can that we
can do to get a step closer to the right
thing
i i used to hang out with a bunch of
mathematicians and
that's basically where i learned
everything that i know and
i remember annoying them one day coming
in being like hey
if only we could define a group
operation that's like a derivative
but you know it works for integrals and
all this nonsense about
trying to figure out a way that we can
make uh derivation the hard
operation and integrals really simple
and all these guys are working on monte
carlo integrators and they just look at
me and they're like
what do you think we do all day
i felt terribly ashamed in that moment
we learned through our mistakes
yeah i want to come back to one thing
before we move on yeah if you don't mind
which is
we talked about this sort of let's say
call it a iq
yeah iq measure right there's this one
kind of thing that sort of annoys me
about a lot of the
ai doomsday sort of thinkers right that
we're going to be killed off by machines
or whatnot
is they assume that aiq can go to
infinity
and that infinity aiq can somehow
warp the laws of nature it's like you're
watching the movie
dark city where they've developed this
technology
where they can control reality with
their minds the only other person i know
that's seen that movie
oh dude that movie so that predates the
matrix by the way for people out there
and presents a very interesting take on
a very similar idea i don't want to
spoil it for anybody but
yeah i highly recommend that movie dark
city i think it's
phenomenal and it provides a lot of deep
thought
it's worth noting if you're watching
that movie in the beginning you're going
to think
this is very odd it feels wooden stick
with it there's reason and after
and after you watch the movie watch the
director's commentary version if you can
because it's fascinating how they
actually use cinematography to convey
these feelings of
lostness and disjoint sort of thing yes
it's pretty cool it's very cool
but again so that's my thing is i don't
think i wonder
is intelligence really infinite in the
sense that
if you were smart enough you could be
like let's say the
the mule in isaac asimov's foundation
series where
i look at you and by wiggling my eye in
a certain way i just interfere with your
mind and cause you to do what i tell you
to do
you know sort of yeah i just i don't
know that that's really the case i don't
think that
even if machines can become smarter than
us fine i think there's a
limit to how much intelligence can rule
the laws of physics
and so i'm not so sure that we're really
going to face a doomsday
and one of one of my big peeves i spend
a lot of time
getting grumpy about social science
research because i love social sciences
is that is that a field of science
i'm just no if it's not if it's got
science in the title
it's not a science people the psychology
of literature is great for this because
they've claimed these huge effects
from from small minor interventions the
wiggling of the eyebrow
and it's just impossible it's impossible
that all these things coexist
they're mining noise but they don't
realize they're doing it and
people keep bringing up the point that
human beings are incredibly complex and
incredibly noisy systems
and even though at the macro scale we
have very common behaviors
even in terms of individual reactions to
small events it's
very hard to predict how an individual
human will respond
unless you hit them with a very large
influence
right do you know werner ving and i'm
not sure if i'm pronouncing his name
right but he wrote
for example a fire upon the deep which
is a very cool science fiction novel
about
ai like ai's become sort of god-like and
they do interesting things
in the galaxy if you will and there's
sort of scene in there where this
malevolent ai
aims a laser beam at one of the
navigational systems of a ship
and by just modulating things in a
certain way is able to hack into it and
take it off
right i have read that yeah oh yeah
that's an interesting idea
if you keep vague tabs on the the weird
and murky world of
cyber weapons there are hints that
that's not as crazy as it sounds
however i don't think it's going to work
for people
because digital systems are digital
systems and they do what they're told
whereas neurons
sometimes they do it they're told
sometimes they behave there's a
resilience there's a resilience to the
processing of their
fuzziness yeah there's an interesting
thing because
i can't remember where i read this it
might have been in the oval no harare's
book
but he said that chickens have got this
problem where
they are attuned to a certain clucking
noise so you can give them a robot
uh baby chicken and as long as it makes
the clucking noise then the
the hen will nurture that robot as if it
was one of one of their own
so it goes to show that even humans we
learn lots of shortcuts
which um might seem intelligent on the
surface but are actually a far cry from
that
and i wanted to just quickly respond to
what keith was saying before so
again charlay has written some
interesting stuff about this
intelligence explosion
and he's got this article on medium
which is called the
impossibility of an intelligence
explosion and these are the
the concluding statements at the end so
he said remember
intelligence is situational there's no
such thing as general intelligence your
brain is just one piece in a broader
system
which includes your body your
environment other humans and so on so
in a roundabout way he's saying that
there are lots of limitations to
intelligence and of course we're an
expression of our environment
but so he says that no system exists in
a vacuum any individual intelligence
will always be
both defined and limited by the context
of its existence
and our environment not our brain is
acting as the bottleneck of our
intelligence
and he said some really interesting
things as well about he was skeptical
about neural link
and and he thinks that putting a neural
link in our brain giving us access to
the internet
isn't going to make us more intelligent
because we're already pretty stupid
we're already quite slow at
understanding you know information as it
is
he says uh intelligence is largely
externalized he even thinks that culture
and books for example
are forms of externalized intelligence
he doesn't like this conception of the
brain as being intelligent
and he said that recursively
self-improving systems because of
contingent bottlenecks
diminished returns and counter reactions
arising from the broader context in
which they exist
cannot achieve exponential progress in
practice
typically they they display linear or
sigmoidal improvement
so he uses the case of science i
remember this so he says even though
there's an exponentially increasing
amount of
research happening in science if you
look at the number of papers published
the actual progress is quite linear
this is a this is a comforting argument
i i don't buy into the doomsday scenario
just
to put this on the record but they're
talking about oh it's in our
civilization
our tooling what happens once we've got
hundreds of thousands of ai agents
or millions billions yeah hundreds of
billions across the solar system
that kind of undercuts this argument a
little bit i don't think they're going
to take over or anything like that
that's
just silly doomsday alarm stuff but
i i think the argument that it will
necessarily be
non-exponential because you know we're
going to achieve linear growth
science at the moment feels pretty
logarithmic and
there comes a point where from the point
of view of a logarithm
a linear growth rate starts to look
pretty exponential
there's some debate about whether that
kind of logarithmic
appearance of progress or maybe it's
root n over n or you know whatever
maybe some arguments have made are made
that's because of us humans
we're the ones who on the other hand you
can argue that it's a
fundamental fact of information
communication
there's different ways to take that i
don't want to i wouldn't
so easily dismiss the doomsday folks i
don't think it's going to happen
either but i just i want somebody to
pose the question to them is
do you think intelligence is infinite
and and can infinite intelligence
control
the reality of physics because they just
ignore
all the sort of realities of physics
right
you don't need infinite intelligence to
be dangerous
and that's true the the safety and ai
literature it's good because they're
actually thinking through these problems
but in a non-alarmist way they're
thinking about what are the
practical problems that we're going to
need to solve what are the realistic
dangers that we may
expect and they they will invoke super
intelligent agents but they say that's a
tail risk but it's a tail risk
that if we solve these other problems by
the time that becomes pertinent
you will be well prepared to tackle
those problems before they become
problems
yeah i i i cool so should i attempt to
talk about this
interactive robert lange one of our
co-conspirators he
he actually told us that this would be a
great thing to talk about and by the way
if we do a search for robert
lange machine learning robert has
pioneered
this kind of this isn't an interactive
article but this is a very creative
article
so he's using animations and and so on
and you might have noticed for example
on distilled.pub so if we do
chris ola i always use this feature
visualization
so distill.pub is is a new type of
it's it's a way of showing information
with lots of visualizations and
simulations and
graphics and and so on and
it's so much better for comprehension
right so some of these things are
actually interactive
and there's a trade-off to doing it this
way personally i love being able to have
information in pdf and i can stick it on
my kindle and so on but
if you think about it some of the
benefits of this new paradigm are
reducing cognitive load and making the
systems playful and
prompting self-reflection connecting
people and data
and personalized reading and so on and i
think you can actually make a lot of
very complex concepts
much more accessible than you otherwise
would have done
yeah so the first thing i want to point
out
is people have been thinking about this
for a long time do me a favor if you
would just on your screen there and
search up for
just type in menard m-i-n-a-r-d
space napoleon russia and let's just
pull up this a very cool
graphic so one of those there see those
images down there
no further down yeah click on one of
those just highlight one of those
so this is a plot he did of napoleon's
march through russia where they start
off as this very
wide fighting force that represents
their kind of size and it shows when
forces break off and go elsewhere and
they start to shrink over time right
taking losses from the weather etc and
by the time they get to as far as they
go they're basically
almost obliterated and then this is
their retreat back in black
this is a beautiful visualization of
data
and people been trying to do this sort
of thing for a very long time and it's a
lot of work
you have to put in tremendous amounts of
human effort
to generate very clear impactful
visual diagrams interactive content
this comment is made in the article
there about
people have been doing uh i forget
what's called but adaptable text
for a while they've been where you can
set it to novice level and that shows
you one paragraph and you up the scale
to intermediate and it shows
you more advanced text and they
commented that this is a lot of work and
difficulty for authors because they have
to write multiple versions of the text
it only gets more and more difficult
when you start to think about creating
impactful visualizations and
more difficult still when it's animation
and more difficult still when we want to
include some music or audio effects
yeah even this youtube channel right
this is we're putting a lot of extra
effort in
to make it visual to edit it afterwards
to make it more accessible so you're
kind of saying that
you can reduce the cognitive load you
can make information more accessible
but it's just more onerous and
scientists basically have got better
stuff to do
they're busy being clever buffins
they're not really
they shouldn't be making their
information more accessible to others
no they i they you're right that they
shouldn't be
maybe maybe every great scientist needs
an assistant
that goes and helps edit their content
to make it interactive
i don't know but i'm just pointing out
that part of the reason why there hasn't
been a lot of progress
or why maybe we don't see as much of
this content as we would like is because
it's not easy to do
well and it takes a tremendous amount of
effort
and even if you're willing to devote the
effort it's often a very difficult
problem i think of
even just a simple app how like how many
times has facebook tweaked and optimized
just that little simple app
right let's move this button over here
and make it five pixels smaller and it
has an effect
on the way people use the thing i know
that's actually just a quick segue on
that because we're going to be talking
about the social dilemma in a few weeks
and they've portrayed it as being very
nefarious that people at facebook are
trying to
manipulate us and trying to make it as
addictive as possible
and i think that was a side effect you
and i both know i think we've all worked
in application development for decades
it used to be called user experience
design and
i think a lot of the the best web
developers at google there was a seven
second rule
and they knew that if it wasn't
responsive in a certain way
that you would not be engaged for very
long
and now that's become so efficient that
they're a b
testing this and they're systematizing
this to such an extreme degree
if you were being a really cynical
person you might think that they were
deliberately trying to hook people on
the platform
like there is this technical overhead
right just to
recenter i won't call back to what we
were talking about two seconds ago about
um
scientists don't have time to do this i
th i think
under the current model and this was
also brought up in the paper under the
current incentive structure for
researchers there's no reason to do this
it's better to
churn out more publications than to have
a good impactful
website that people can truly understand
your ideas
and i think part of the way forward here
in an abstract sense is to embrace the
open science model
to instead of thinking in terms of peer
review which
god bless the current epidemic has shown
to
completely break down when put under
pressure
things like post review things like open
post review you
put out a paper and people can criticize
it and you can improve the work because
it's not about a publication ultimately
science isn't about publications it's
about building knowledge
and the more people that can uh
criticize and contribute
and build on an idea and again human
nature being what it is these are all
lovely statements the
actual implementation would be different
but like instead of just putting these
papers out on archive or something like
that
developing these these sort of
interactive pages on sites like
distill and having them open to
collaboration
so you may not be you may be like a
student working on a problem and you're
channeling all your effort into this but
no one's understanding you but you can
pair up with someone who
can build a visualization and they get
partial credit for the contribution for
communicating the idea
if someone finds a flaw in your theorem
and they contribute a solution
and it i don't know how it would work it
would look like wikipedia but
different but thinking in
beyond the model of standard publication
in fact
thinking beyond the model of standard
authorship may be the way to address
that cognitive overload
yeah that's really interesting because
um the article talks about research debt
it calls it out and it says that one of
the problems is that
we lose perspective of the bigger
picture right because people aren't
understanding what's going on
and that that can cause a kind of
convergence
there's also the credit assignment
problem and and there's this issue
i don't know if you heard about in
europe's and and the problem with the
the whole peer review system is broken
basically and that the second reviewer
can kill your work
and there's no incentive there because
there's no reputation on the line
because it's an anonymous system and
usually they can figure out what
institution you work for
beforehand anyway and it all kind of
links into this bigger picture that
there's no real incentive to have a
an open system if archive for example if
they had
um public comments on your work because
at the moment
there's there's an open review site
where you can have some kind of
real collaboration but as you just
suggested what if research was a
continuous thing
what if folks could just add to your
work and it just went on and on
well i think it it almost has to start
working like that because there's
you archive sanity exists for a reason
there's thousands of papers on machine
learning released
every day most of them will never be
read by anyone
and that talking about informational
efficiency there's a reason the gains
are slowing down it's because the space
is saturated
but if you could find a way of of doing
credit assignment
and that again this is hard but
crediting people for contributing
to a larger project in an open and
transparent way
where disagreements could be resolved
without someone deleting
the entire body of work and people who
are strong coders or engineers could
optimize
one side people who knew how to
communicate ideas
through through written word or through
visualizations
everyone plays their role in
contributing
it may be an idealized system but it
given the technology we have
how much of it's just a failure of
imagination that we that we're not
already doing
yeah i was just about to point that out
we almost have a system that
supports that now we have the internet
we have multimedia html5 can do
in any manner of animations multimedia
content
i don't know if the toolset is that
friendly to use or not but
it's kind of asking for is the internet
maybe with some
little bit of modification but it's not
a hard idea but like a lot of these big
research bottlenecks aren't unsolvable
it's funny you say we need the internet
because i agree that the internet is the
fundamental democratizing force and we
have
html and all of this stuff in the
article it says that the united nations
have even
they want to protect the status of the
internet from interference
because they think it's a fundamental
human right but
national preserve at some point we have
to make it a world
world heritage site so you can't hang on
you're the american here you're meant to
be against socializing
public assets oh i'm what i am
for what i am for is humor at almost any
cost
so i i do even at my own personal cost
so that that's why i make comments like
that
it's exactly but i think we are to a
certain extent wasting the modern web
because it's interactive and most of the
most of the content out there isn't and
a lot of that is because we consume
via multiple channels and multiple
devices so it's become a bit lowest
common denominator
the article said places like wordpress
and media and they
they're optimizing on social networking
as opposed to the interactivity of
content
but i wanted to just quickly point out
an example a lot of that's because of
the audience which is that
so i can't tell you how many times i've
been reading a white paper
and looking through various kind of
diagrams and whatnot and just thinking
to myself
can you just show me the system of
equations
please because i've already developed
the ability
to look at those equations and i have
the abstract whatever's in my neural net
to
to take that input efficiently and i
don't want to have to go through
all the the kind of hand holding whereas
another audience
might get a lot of value out of that i i
will raise my hand and say i'm that
other audience i'm
self-taught in maths and especially when
i'm reading physics papers or something
what you've got an e here what's the e
is this an expectation is this an
operator is this the energy function
what's going on here
but the within the paper itself
the complexity slider was a great idea
and i loved the idea
of that was attributed to someone of
annotations for your equations
that's such a thing you could toggle
them on and off that was really
yeah perfect you're reading a paper in
an unfamiliar domain
switch on the subtitles so you can
understand it a little more easily
yeah an important aspect of this and
that's an important point that you bring
up
is to some degree the more that we can
make it
accessible without going too far but the
more we make it accessible the more we
can
enable i would hope greater achievement
i would say though it's it's got a
double-edged sword because i read a
couple comments in the paper that gave
me pause
uh like i'm going to read you this quote
so unit visualizations have also been
used to evoke
empathy in readers in other words
covering
grim topics such as gun deaths right
and he goes on to say something else to
which i can't put my finger on it right
now but
oh yeah he instead suggests
anthropomorphizing data
borrowing journalistic and rhetoric
techniques to create
novel designs or interventions to foster
empathy and readers when viewing
visualizations
and i'm sitting here thinking i'm
sitting here thinking okay if i'm doing
science and i'm trying to apply logic
and science to
fact based to find things that are real
and true
do i want to be invoking emotion
in people yeah i don't they were talking
about oh it can be used in various
things
education research etc and then they
said policy
and my concern is okay we're going to
use empathy to make a more convincing
argument
and now we're going to apply it to the
real world via policy who's got the
bigger budgets
to present these better arguments and
this is what happens anyway because
as you say there's one thing which is
dissemination of information and making
it as comprehensible as possible
but then there's persuasion and all of
this evoking
empathy stuff but a lot of it is just
like marketing
and a lot of the when you design
applications or when you
design presentations and you talk to
creative types that's what it's all
about it's about creating a story and
evoking emotion
and a lot of this if you look at the
venn diagram it's very much in that
domain
yeah yeah and so this is like a lot of
tools uh
can be used for good or for ill and i
think using it to
make information more accessible to help
people actually understand it from a
factual point of view
those are all very noble pursuits using
it to yet
further tweak people's emotions
i think is not so great that's just
gonna
further and there's some other comment
in the paper that made me realize
yeah that could just further oh yeah one
of the things he brings up at the very
top
personalize reading let readers choose
the content that is relevant to their
own experience
okay if we're talking about intellectual
experience like we were saying earlier
add annotations to this equation and
help me explain it
wonderful if on the other hand we're
talking about my demographic
i don't know that's just going to help
further flame and polarize people
and face algorithmic feedback loops
based on recommended systems we know
this is a problem
the internet it's quite it's quite
dangerous because that's what social
media does now is that you see the
reality that you want to see
and this lived experience thing is very
dangerous because the
the french philosophers there's this
focus an idea that
your reality is constructed from
language and that's quite a dangerous
place to go down but
i wanted to quickly demonstrate one
other thing on here so there's a
wonderful example called a visual
introduction to machine learning
and this is actually called scrolly
telling or data journalism or something
and
apparently scrolly telling has been
demonstrated to be
no better than slideware but this is an
example of a wonderful
intuitive experience teaching machine
learning concepts
and i want to touch on what keith was
saying earlier because keith was
basically saying
not in a snobbish way but is this about
making it more accessible
to people that wouldn't otherwise
understand and i don't think it's
necessarily
making it more accessible to people
lower down the totem problem if you look
at the annex channel for example
he's making machine learning concepts
more accessible to people that are
studying a phd in it
so it's not that it can't be used for
sophisticated folks it's just that it
hasn't been used yet
yeah look accessibility is not about low
or high to me it's just about
breadth and i don't i totally believe
people can contribute to
fields from anywhere i think it's it is
an efficiency thing which is
if i'm a scientist and i communicate
effectively to another scientist
society gains x amount of forward
progress in in science and if i
communicate it efficiently to
say a layman that just likes it as a
hobby and thinks it's cool
do i make any progress towards science
so it's just about where we invest our
resources
and if we ever could get at a state
where alex is talking about where it's
it's more
open and crowdsourced and yet people are
still motivated to contribute i
sort of the internet but with maybe some
enhancements
modification better tooling uh some
cryptocurrency that tracks how much
you've contributed
i was waiting for blockchain to come up
it always
had to do then that's all great
it's just and by the way when you were
scrolling through that scrolly vision i
want to point out
for those who maybe are weren't around
back in let's say
the mid to late 90s or late 90s when
when
html was brand new and cool and
everybody was exploring what the web
could do
there were innumerable websites that
tried to do really cool
visual layouts like that flash
sort of things and i spent lots of time
perusing them because i thought these
are neat
and wow look at that and i even made
some websites where i tried to do cool
visualization
and then you fast forward decades and
the sort of natural selection and
darwinian evolution is the internet is
that we've streamlined it and simplified
it to wordpress
so if you're a darwinianist you may just
believe that
what we're arriving at right now is just
the efficient way
of of presenting information for the
population as a whole because we had all
these tricks and cool things back then
and people stopped doing it so we
weren't getting as much value out of it
well the thing because the internet was
an incredibly exciting time because in
in 1999 me and a guy called thomas
bradley we ran
a website called dhtmlcentral.com and
we were on the forefront of any of those
guys went on to become very senior
people at google
in the subsequent years and we were on
the forefront of doing that i
but the problem was even then it was
difficult and now it's still difficult
coding is difficult it hasn't got easier
and
yeah as you say on on the balance of
things
it's much more efficient especially
given that we've got certain
distribution mechanisms over multiple
channels
it's much easier just to use text and to
focus on the social
so where where is the place for this
stuff to bring that up expand that a
little bit further
it's not just that it's more efficient
it's that bad writing is far more
forgiving than bad
code if you've got bad badly coded or
badly supported code
you have unusable information whereas if
you've got just something that's
poorly slapped together poorly phrased
then that's at least
salvageable you can do something with
that
this is maybe this is where neural link
comes in because we keep coming back to
look just
natural language well written in a way
that creates visuals within your mind
and storytelling is
the most efficient thing that human
beings communicate with right now
that's the problem we need to hook up
some wires in there so we can just input
some more efficient
form of media then we won't even need
interactive websites because it'll just
be an interactive wire
i know but charlay said that's a load of
rubbish because
if you increase the reading speed the
cognition goes down
there there are um hard limitations and
i know we debated the other week that
maybe you could represent it in a
different way but yeah i think
the brain is much slower than we realize
yeah the meat space bottleneck is io
yeah not even i o even comprehending the
information
so i think it's it's because we can read
information far faster than we can
comprehend it already
yeah that's fair that's fit maybe it's
slow because actually what it's doing is
quite difficult
which is it's creating these concepts
these ideas it's creating structures
right all the things that we keep saying
we would love it if
neural networks could do and they
utterly fail at doing
our brain is doing that and so it's
doing a difficult computational problem
and because it's an efficiently designed
temporal computation
parallel computation device it just
takes a certain amount of time to
to calculate that stuff and organize it
and on that note gentlemen it's been an
absolute pleasure
likewise thank you and thank you for
joining us so late and your evening alex
really appreciate it
uh it's it's a lovely evening i had a
good excuse to sit up and have a nice
cup of tea so
why not what time is it there alex
12 30. not too late oh my god oh my god
and you've got another one with us
tomorrow yeah but that one's that one's
easy that's 5 p.m i can do that one
i'm at my best at midnight this is my
prime coding time so
amazing well written code i hope
oh you know it's minimal bug fixing
tomorrow morning let's say
well tony horror has this brilliant
quote there are two ways to do software
design
you either make it so simple there are
obviously no errors
or you make it so complicated there are
no obvious errors
[Laughter]
bug or feature you decide oh that is
brilliant i think we need to
have that as the intro to the show
see you guys thank you